comment c'est cette table ronde qui est
consacrée à l'Outre-mer en nous excusant
pour ce retard puisque voilà on avait
une autre table ronde qui a été très
très riche en débat et je suis convaincu
que la nôtre cette scie va avoir
également la même richesse des changes
donc une partie des personnes sont en
présentiel dans la salle ici et d'autres
sont en visio j'espère que voilà la
connexion se fera de la façon la plus
satisfaisante possible tout au long de
ces échanges donc cette table ronde
consacrée la rénovation énergétique des
logements en outre-mer alors nous
accueillons l'Union Sociale d'organismes
HLM outre-mer
ushom qui est représenté par sa
directrice Madame Sabrina Mathiot que
l'on a vu un court instant à l'écran et
qui n'arrivait pas à brancher son micro
je pense qu'elle va arriver à donc à
nous à nous rejoindre ou à se
reconnecter
nous avons ici dans la salle l'Union
sociale pour l'habitat en outre-mer
Ush O2M qui représenté par Monsieur
Brian sowrana qui est directeur
d'outre-mer et par Monsieur Rémi Vasseur
qui est responsable du département
énergie et bas carbone au sein de la
direction de la maîtrise d'ouvrage
l'Union sociale pour l'habitant que nous
avons déjà entendu lors d'une audition
précédente représente les organismes
d’hlm et puis le centre d'innovation et
de recherche du bâti tropical le sirbat
représenté par son directeur Monsieur
Frédéric chanfain Le sirbat est un pôle
d'innovation qui est porté par la
Chambre de Métiers et de l'Artisanat de
la Réunion il mène des recherches sur
l'adaptation des matériaux de
construction et des normes aux réalités
des milieux tropicaux enfin le conseil
nationale de l'Ordre des architectes de
la Réunion Mayotte qui est représentée
par son président Monsieur Maxence
Lefebvre madame messieurs le travail de
notre commission d'enquête ne saurait
être complet sans que nous évoquions les
enjeux de la rénovation des logements
énergétiques des logements dans les
outre-mer en effet ces collectivités
présentent une situation spécifique leur
climat tropical à l'exception de
Saint-Pierre et Miquelon et distinct de
celui de la métropole on pourrait croire
dès lors que la rénovation y énergétique
n'y est pas un enjeu fort mais au
contraire il s'agit d'un sujet qui
concerne au premier plan les outre-mer
nous avons souligné à plusieurs reprises
au cours de nos auditions que le confort
d'été c'est à dire la protection face à
la chaleur est un aspect fondamental des
politiques de rénovation énergétique
les outre-mer sans par ailleurs tout
aussi concernés par les enjeux de
précarité énergétique et de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
pouvez-vous ainsi nous présenter les
principaux enjeux de la rénovation
énergétique des logements dans les
outre-mer de plus les matériaux utilisés
dans la construction dans les outre-mer
sont spécifiques au milieu tropicaux
leur caractéristiques en termes de
durabilité et d'isolation nécessite des
recherches adaptées ainsi que
pouvez-vous nous faire ainsi pouvez-vous
de faire un état des lieux de
l'utilisation des matériaux biosourcés
dans les outre-mer dans la rénovation
énergétique y a-t-il des contraintes à
leur développement
enfin la rénovation des bâtiments dans
les outre-mer doivent doit répondre à
des contraintes propres en particulier
ils doivent pouvoir résister à des
événements
météorologiques extrêmes comme des
cyclones est-ce qu'il y a des synergies
entre ces travaux et ceux de la
rénovation énergétique ou au contraire
excusez-moi
est-ce que privilégiez
l'un peut se faire au détriment de
l'autre
avant de vous laisser la parole pour
répondre à ses premières questions il me
revient de vous indiquer que l'audition
est diffusé en direct et en différé sur
le site internet du Sénat et qu'un
compte rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité a levé la main
droite et à dire je le jure on va
commencer ici par vous messieurs qui est
en présentiel
je le jure
je le jure madame et messieurs à votre
tour si vous pouvez se vous prêter à ce
formalisme
on vous entend toujours pas Madame
Mathieu
on vous entend toujours pas
bon on va passer aux autres messieurs
avant parfait messieurs
je le jure
je le jure voilà je vous remercie alors
on va peut-être commencer d'abord par en
présentiel et puis ensuite on passera à
Madame et messieurs qui est en visio
je vous remercie madame la présidente
madame la Présidente Mesdames les vices
présidentes et Messieurs les vices
présidents monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames sénatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs mesdames et messieurs tout
d'abord au nom de l'Union sociale pour
l'habitat que nous présentons
aujourd'hui avec Monsieur Rémi Vasseur
et Alban charrier permettez-nous de vous
remercier pour votre invitation à cette
table ronde organisée par la commission
d'enquête sur l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique comme vous l'avez
indiqué madame la Présidente le sujet de
nos échanges portera aujourd'hui sur le
département et région d'outre-mer en
propos liminaire j'indiquerai que très
rapidement pour ce qui concerne l'Union
sociale pour l'habitat depuis 30 ans la
mission première devenue depuis quelques
années une direction assure au sein de
l'USH qui représente près de 600
adhérents en France hexagonale et dans
les outre-mer l'organisation et
l'animation du dossier de la politique
nationale du logement social en faveur
des acteurs du secteur dans les dromes
aussi bien que dans les com quand nous
sommes invité travailler ce travail est
conduit pour une action concertée en
matière d'affaires publiques et
d'élaboration de propositions
législatives et réglementaires la
relation l'appui et l'animation de
l'action professionnelle dédiée aux
organismes HLM dans les outre-mer la
communication et la diffusion des
actions de l'USA auprès des organismes
dans les territoires ultramarins le
développement du partenariat avec les
instances professionnelles et
associatives partenaires services de
l'État que vous connaissez aussi bien le
Parlement
et enfin un partenariat avec les
associations régionales des maîtrises
d'ouvrages des maîtres d'oeuvre
d'ouvrages sociaux pardon dans le sang
indien la Guadeloupe et en Guyane pour
l'organisation des activités telles que
des séminaires dédiés aux bailleurs
sociaux
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur aujourd'hui le secteur reste
marqué par une forte baisse de l'offre
de logements neufs en locatif et en
accession par la persistance de
l'habitat indigne estimé à 155 000
logements sur 16% du parc total des
drumes un fort besoin de réhabilitation
du parc locatif social et la hausse des
coûts de revient du logement social
exacerbé par la forte évolution de
l'inflation pour rappel le parc de
logements social et d'environ 172000
logements dans les dromes et environ
19000 logements dans les cônes tout de
Rome confondu le nombre de demandes de
logements social enregistré en 2022
atteint près de 80
000 demandes enfin sur la programmation
de logement neuf pour l'année 2022 4800
logements sociaux en locatif à un
accession ont été financés mais
seulement 2800 logements issus des
programmations des années précédentes
ont été livrées on estimerait que ce
serait une baisse de 12% au monde de
logements sociaux financés 11% en nombre
de logements sociaux livré
sur les principaux enjeux de la
rénovation énergétique dans les
outre-mer qui est le sujet de notre
échange d'aujourd'hui nous rappellerons
en préambule ce que disait madame la
Présidente de l'USH Emmanuel cosse le
secteur HLM veut être au rendez-vous des
enjeux de la débat des carbonation du
parc résidentiel ainsi les principaux
enjeux de la rénovation d'outre-mer
rejoignent les enjeux globaux à savoir
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique
en participant à la décarbonation du
secteur du logement résidentiel et celui
du logement social en particulier la
réduction des consommations énergétiques
afin d'inscrire le patrimoine dans les
objectifs de la loi climat et résilience
la protection des occupants en face ou
hausse des prix de l'énergie et
l'amélioration continue de l'autonomie
et énergétique dans nos territoires des
Outre-mer la réussite de l'atteinte de
ces enjeux doit impérativement passer
par une prise en compte sérieuse et
concertée des spécificités climatiques
géographiques ainsi que des usages
propres aux populations de nos dromcom
ces grands objectifs se confrontent à
une difficulté opérationnelle qui
devient l'enjeu majeur pour les
outre-mer en effet l'ensemble des
politiques de rénovation énergétique
doivent s'appuyer sur une démarche
d'état des lieux puis de programmation
de mise en œuvre et enfin de contrôle
l'outil réglementaire pour la mise en
œuvre d'une stratégie de rénovation et
aujourd'hui le DPE or bien que la loi
climat et résilience prévoit l'entrée en
vigueur du DPE opposable dans les
territoires d'outre-mer raconter du 1er
juillet 2024 ce dernier n'est pas encore
finalisé pour rappel le DPE s'applique
uniquement au bâtiment régulé en termes
de température interne que l'on soit en
chauffage ou en climatisation des
dispositifs existent aussi bien en
Guadeloupe avec le DPEG quand Martinique
avec le dpem
tous les autres territoires on possèdent
pas hors une directive européenne pose
aujourd'hui cette étiquette énergétique
sur les bâtiments et l'ensemble des
territoires
concernant l'état des lieux énergétiques
des logements dans les outre-mer comme
indiqué précédemment l'état du parc au
regard du nouvel outil des pays dome il
n'est pas possible de faire un état des
lieux aussi exhaustif que vous le
souhaiteriez car l'outil n'est pas
encore finalisé et tant au niveau de la
méthode de calcul qu'au niveau des
seuils définissant les classes
énergétiques des logements nous
précisons cependant qu'en groupe de
travail de la DHP et de la dgom à lancer
en avril 2023
une étude qui porte sur deux objectifs
une phase d'analyse comparative des
outils existants avec une prise en
compte des outils et des premiers
retours attendus pour septembre et une
phase de modélisation du parc
résidentiel du tramarin afin de répondre
aux besoins de disposer de données sur
la performance énergétique du parc de
chaque Drôme ce serait pour 2024 sur la
fin de cette deuxième phase à ce jour
concernant les réglementations
spécifiques qui sont applicables dans
les outre-mer en termes de rénovation
énergétique des logements oui le DPE en
premier lieu sera spécifique afin de
prendre en compte les spécificités des
territoires d'outre-mer il est
indispensable que cet outil intègre au
mieux les spécificités de chaque
territoire au risque d'imposer des
solutions inadaptées
le confort des bâtiments à la chaleur
nécessitera une natation particulière à
un développement spécifique au sujet des
spécificités du parc social en outre-mer
et d'un point de vue énergétique les
constructions dans les dromes doivent
respecter une réglementation thermique
astuce acoustique et d'aération et donc
disposer par exemple d'une eau chaude
dans tous les logements de l'offre sauf
dans certaines communes de Guyane et de
Mayotte recourir à l'énergie solaire
pour satisfaire au moins 50% des besoins
en eau chaude sanitaire pour toutes les
installations de production réduire les
dépenses énergétiques des bâtiments et
améliorer le confort hydrothermique des
habitants améliorer la qualité de l'air
optimiser le confort acoustique des
logements réduire la consommation
d'énergie des bâtiments avec des enjeux
prioritaires au niveau de la transition
écologique le temps de choses à faire
voilà pour nos territoires des travaux
de concertation étaient l'ancien avec
les acteurs de la filière l'application
de la future rtadom se concentrera dans
un premier temps sur l'habitation pour
le moment l'objectif est de définir
uniquement des obligations de résultats
en partie thermique et cela via un
indice de confort thermique de référence
sur la base de simulation c'est cet
outil thermique qui est développé en ce
moment par le CSTB et qui va qui
inspirer par des outils existants étant
en cours de tests et qui a besoin encore
de concours des de nos organismes de
logements sociaux ultramarin très
rapidement pour rappel la version
actuelle du RTA Dom repose sur des
critères de moyens la loi du 18 pour un
état au service d'une société de
confiance ambitionne de modifier le CCH
en intégrant la notion d'obligation de
résultats via la mise en place
d'indicateurs de performance adaptée
concernant les synergies entre ces
travaux et sur la résistance à des
événements météorologiques extrêmes
comme les cyclones dans le cas de la
rénovation énergétique nous pensons
qu'il ne faut pas opposer les deux
enjeux qui sont finalement très liés et
très important pour l'avenir de nos
outre-mer et plus largement pour la
France dans son ensemble
peut-être que le CNA CNOA pourra nous
donner plus d'éléments sur le sujet en
effet
en équation énergétique se mêlent avec
bien plus de force qu'en hexagone à
d'autres problématiques qui parfois
passent pour prioritaire les risques
naturels mal au logement le foncier une
fois donc développer plus d'études enfin
c'est notre avis pour le coup avec des
financements pérennes pour pouvoir avoir
une plus grande lisibilité sur ses
enjeux là j'ajouterons qu'il faudra des
appuis sur la structuration des
expertises qui existent mais qui sont
peu interconnectés d'un territoire
l'autre dans les drones la mise en place
de référentiels nécessaires à la mise en
œuvre des travaux de réhabilitation
énergétique en milieu tropical pour les
climatropicaux et enfin nous invitons à
voir les travaux du programme comme
ombré qui est piloté par la QC qui
participe à la résolution de ces
problèmes mathématiques en créant du
lien entre les territoires par exemple
sur la paix ou pergola voilà ce sont des
amis en cherchant des moyens pérennes de
produire d’adapter les référentiels par
exemple l'acide la construction durable
ayant développant la connaissance pour
répondre à des besoins spécifiques des
études retours d'expérience sur la pose
102 ans en climat tropical ou sur les
façades toitures végétalisées voilà pour
cette première partie en luminaire on
répondra bien évidemment avec plaisir
l'ensemble des autres questions qui
viendront et une note bien évidemment
vous sera adressée madame la Présidente
Monsieur rapporteur merci Monsieur
est-ce que vous voulez rajouter quelque
chose
non pas à ce stade plutôt qu'en d'autres
questions se reposer j'ai peut-être
juste complété un tout petit peu ce qui
était dit sur les financements parce que
on était un petit peu dessus sur la fin
donc ça permet de rester dans la
thématique c'est dire que si les deux
thématiques s'opposent pas il faudra
aussi les financer et donc ça veut dire
que certains financements
de l'énergie ils peuvent ne pas être
adaptés pour adressé ses problématiques
qui peuvent être spécifiques autour du
parasismique du paracyclonique et des
sujets un peu connexes qui sont qui
rentrent dans les spécificités de ces
territoires donc il faudra également
dépasser peut-être certains clivages
financiers pour arriver à dresser ces
sujets merci
Madame Mathieu est-ce que vous
on va peut-être vous laisser la parole
oui voilà on peut désoler la connexion
n'est pas terrible de là où je vous
appelle est-ce que vous m'entendez très
bien
Madame la présidente Madame la
vice-présidente monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
d'abord je tiens vraiment à vous
remercier d'avoir réservé un moment
dédié à la fois au logement social
ultramarin et puis à la question de la
rénovation et de la de sa décarbonation
dans le cadre évidemment de la loi
climat énergie qui nous touche et puis
qui nous concerne de très près
nécessairement alors compte tenu des
solutions qu'il représente le logement
social et la nécessité qu'il évolue
qu'il s'adapte et d'autant plus
importante sur nos territoires eu égard
la spécificité des ménages alors
spécificité en ce sens que il y a une
population effectivement un peu plus
fragile des ménages qui ont qui
nécessitent un accompagnement peut-être
un peu plus accrue vous le savez 80% des
citoyens en tout cas des familles sont
éligibles au logement social il en va
donc à la fois du logement de ces
citoyens mais aussi de leur dégager des
marges de manoeuvre dans leur dans leur
vie de tous les jours dans leur et
améliorer leurs conditions de vie en
leur permettant d'avoir le moins de
dépenses possible liées notamment à
l'énergie donc ça c'est peut-être on
propose liminaire j'aimerais inscrire
mon propos donc en fait ce qui est donc
c'est 160 un peu plus de 170 000
logements sociaux dans les outre-mer on
représente à peu près 15% du parc donc
le parc social représente 15%
de deux logements donc c'est pour cela
qu'il est important aussi que les
politiques et les enjeux aussi
financiers liés à l'accompagnement
intègre bien la dimension l'importance
du social certes mais également du privé
je me veux assez impartial et juste à ce
propos même si je suis là pour
représenter le secteur public
j'aimerais également préciser un élément
qui me semble très important c'est c'est
les statistiques
je crois qu'il est nécessaire de dire
que à bien des gares il reste encore des
statistiques une data à compléter à
fiabiliser en tout cas consolider j'en
veux pour preuve la dernière en a
enquête nationale sur le logement qui
qui est faite par l'ONR observatoire
national de la rénovation énergétique et
qui n'intègre pas nos territoires je
pense qu'on manque encore de Data et
donc ces éléments me permettent de
mesurer et d'inscrire vraiment nos
propos dans dans sa limite qui est celle
que on n'a pas véritablement une
connaissance accrue des taux d'efforts
des ménages ultramarins en matière de
dépenses énergétique et de précarité
énergétique on arrive à sentir le pot à
travers d'autres indicateurs de suivi
[Musique]
le climat tropical pour les Antilles et
plutôt
équatoriales pour la Guyane il y a quand
même des nécessites des nécessités à
intégrer cela je dis cela parce que
la nouvelle la loi climat avait donc à
initié
ce principe cette obligation de
rénovation s'appuyant sur l'outil du DPE
donc on connaissait évidemment la RTA
d'homme qui avait intégré cette
dimension de diagnostic mais les
diagnostics locaux qui sont d'ailleurs
assez différents
et bien d'un territoire à un autre
sont bâtis sur
des conceptions en tout cas la
conception de confort dans les outre-mer
doit absolument être appréciées
différemment donc on a le zonage
climatique qui est la base de la
définition même du confort thermique à
ce jour s'agissant des des climats
tropicaux et équatoriaux et bien on ne
dispose pas de de j'ai envie de dire
d'une définition conventionnelle du
confort thermique parfois de conséquence
les DPE qui aujourd'hui d'ailleurs les
nouveaux DPE qui a soit les deux
critères la performance énergétique et
puis les matériaux ne peuvent pas
nécessairement
traduire grand chose sur ces territoires
là ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
naturellement on peut pas concevoir un
confort thermique au chaud dans les
régions chaudes comme on les conçoit
dans l'Hexagone parce qu'on aimerait pas
avoir 19 degrés partout dans nos pièces
à vivre donc aujourd'hui le j'ai envie
de dire d'usage on parle d'un écart type
de température qui est à 4 degrés pour
parler de d'ores et déjà de confort
thermique et cette notion en tout cas
même si on est dans les groupes de le
groupe de travail qui va établir le DPE
il faut absolument qu'elle soit prise en
un mot peut-être sur l'état du parc
social
outre-mer en matière j'ai envie de dire
en matière on critère vert si je puis
m'exprimer m'exprimer ainsi c'est dire
que le parc social reste quand même plus
confort plus performant que le parc
privé alors c'est assez naturel parce
que les politiques de l'habitat social
dans ces territoires a démarré à peu
près 20 ans avec 20 ans de retard par
voie de conséquences le parc est un peu
plus jeune d'ailleurs les bailleurs
sociaux ultramarins sont deux fois plus
endettés pour que les bailleurs
leurs homologues de l'Hexagone il en
résulte que au-delà donc de ce démarrage
tardif on a avec l'arrivée de
Léa d'homme donc l'instauration de la
défiscalisation une dynamique qui avait
été qui avait impulsé le secteur du
logement social qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons à peu près un tiers de notre
parc qui date de 2010 alors les chiffres
sont approximatifs mais les études à la
fois sur la défiscalisation et sur le
logement qu'on a en notre possession et
puis notre connaissance du parc de
auprès de nos bailleurs nous conduisent
à confirmer cette
ordre de grandeur et donc étant
construit donc ce tiers quasiment tiers
de parc ayant été construits après 2010
il était assujetti à la réglementation
RTA d'homme qui déjà avait intégré une
notion de de confort thermique notamment
à travers la ventilation la ventilation
naturelle donc je pense que
on n'est pas j'ai envie de dire qu'on
est assez
naturellement on va épouser le la courbe
et la participation à cette à cette
dynamique de décarbonation mais je pense
que le constat est déjà fait à ce niveau
là
je vais essayer de
limiter mes propos pour aller à
l'essentiel
juste dire que le deuxième le deuxième
élément qui participe à un parc
performant c'est que les bailleurs
sociaux dans les outre-mer n'équipe pas
les bâtiments de de
d'équipement de refroidissement pour
autant il faut absolument signaler et on
commence à avoir des chiffres parce
qu'on a organisé justement des échanges
autour de cela
même si le bailleur ne pose pas
d'équipements parce que la RTA dome
appelle à la ventilation par l'extérieur
donc à des ouvertures
et bien il y a quand même des personnes
des locataires qui quand ils arrivent
dans le parc ils décident d'installer
une climatisation et je m'en propos se
veut j'ai envie de dire encore
d'innersion avec justement
l'intervention par exemple de la prime
en fait agir plus qui accorde des
financements au locataire pour poser sa
climatisation alors malheureusement ça
vient s'inscrire en dissonance absolue
avec la dynamique qui est impulsée
techniquement par la RTA d'homme c'est à
dire que le bailleur construit des
logements qui sont faits pour être
ouverts sur l'extérieur avec vous savez
des jalousies ces espèces de fenêtres
qui s'ouvrent et qui sont pas somme
toutes qui sont pas faites pour isoler
votre environnement donc quand vous
arrivez pour déposer un équipement on
s'inscrit absolument au four avec ce qui
est initié initialement et là-dessus
j'aimerais dire que même si on se
félicite de des interventions de DDF qui
sont d'ailleurs très importantes dans
les autres mères pour ce qui est du parc
privé bien sûr
il faut absolument qu'on revoit notre
façon de fonctionner sur sur ces
éléments sur l'eau chaude sanitaire qui
est également financée pour ce qui est
des ménages individuels on parle pas du
parc privé mais pour le bailleur social
s'est intégré là encore depuis le depuis
la rtadom donc on a construit le shoot
sanitaire maintenant elle est on utilise
les panneaux solaires alors il s'est
avéré et d'après les retours nos
bailleurs que c'est
contre-productif alors c'est assez
rentable sur le plan environnemental sur
le plan financier il y a quelque chose à
repenser parce que l'entretien de ces
équipements pour le bailleur avec les
charges récupérables sur les locataires
pèse lourd dans les dans les charges des
locataires par conséquent
il y a sans doute il y a par exemple du
photovoltaïque qu'on pourrait porter
autrement qui serait moins coûteux et
qui pèserait moins sur les ménages alors
l'idée bien sûr chez le bailleur c'est à
la fois de répondre aux exigences
réglementaires sont jamais pesées sur
sur le locataire qui est déjà bien
fragile et donc voilà donc du coup là
encore ça nécessite une coordination
je crois que le
l'élément d'éléments qui est important
sur les financements et sur le peut-être
les choses qui restent à progresser
c'est que le retour qu'on en a pour le
moins c'est que d'abord il faut cette
notion de confort thermique il faut une
définition conventionnelle avec un DPE
qui soit donc cohérent avec ses climat
il faut absolument une différenciation
parce qu'on peut pas considérer
effectivement que la réunion soit
absolument dans le même dans le même
état que
que les que les Antilles le deuxième
élément c'est que s'agissons des
financements aujourd'hui on va
privilégier des financements qui ne vont
pas toujours dans les dynamiques
sociales et écologiques alors que l'idée
c'est quand même de s'inscrire dans les
deux et de prévoir la coordination les
travaux de réhabilitation aujourd'hui
sur le parc des Outre-mer au même titre
d'ailleurs que que ceux qui sont en lien
avec
renforcement c'est SMIC parasylonique
peuvent être justement
l'occasion si on donnait bien sûr un
coup de pouce enfin si en prévoyait des
dispositifs et des outils de financement
qui soient adéquats peuvent t'aider
à créer une dynamique très positive y
compris sur le parc social
il faut savoir que l'intervention des
certificats par exemple d'économie
d'énergie en outre-mer je crois que
c'est 1,2 % alors qu'il y a encore de la
marge de manœuvre à ce niveau là et
les interventions d'EDF d'ailleurs je
crois que c'est il finance en partie le
programme et codom que nous portons pour
changer les usages et ça ce sera
peut-être le dernier élément et on peut
agir sur l'enveloppe d'une façon
moins importante parce que la rtadom
avait posé sur des ventilations
naturelles de la cohérence quand on pose
des équipements il faut un
accompagnement financier pour le parc
social qui est quand même inexistant
aujourd'hui alors qu'on finance les
équipements qui certes créent du confort
mais qui créent aussi se faisant des
passoires thermiques il faut qu'il y ait
un choix en tout cas un consensus qui se
trouve à ce niveau là
et le troisième élément c'est les
changements comportementaux parce que on
peut agir en outre-mer sur les sur les
sur les usages et avoir un impact plus
important peut-être aussi que c'est pour
cela qu'on avait fait ce choix de créer
un dispositif qui permette la formation
des ménages aux économies d'énergie
parce que ça peut être très rentable un
petit point sur Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
je voudrais dire que
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon je crois que
EDF dépense 8 millions d'euros par an
alors que je crois que le CA le chiffre
d'affaires c'est 4 millions d'euros ces
chiffres date de 2021
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon c'est un
territoire très important il est classé
aujourd'hui alors en zone H1 en zone
climatique c'est le seul territoire
d'outre-mer qui se retrouve dans le
classement
hexagonal alors qu'on devrait permettre
des accompagnements plus beaucoup plus
important parce que vraiment c'est
beaucoup plus dépensier l'année dernière
fin d'année 2022 l'État a dépensé un
million d'euros d'aide au ménage de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon cet argent a
servi à payer l'augmentation du fioul
parce qu'évidemment tout est produit par
le fioul alors qu'il aurait pu servir de
façon pertinente sur et bien
l'accompagnement par exemple du parc qui
est qui est prévu et entendu que on
aurait pu convenir d'une co-construction
d'une politique énergétique avec le
Canada ou un pays qui soit à côté mais
là il s'agit de souveraineté c'est
d'autant plus important pour
Saint-Pierre et Miquelon que c'est
symptôme qui n'ouvre donc pas droit au
fond vert enfin les fonds européens vert
sauf le fait je crois il y a quelque
chose mais rien à voir avec avec les
fonds verts donc voilà ce que je
pourrais dire et puis je suis ouverte
pour recevoir vos questions merci merci
beaucoup donc on va passer la question
on va passer à Monsieur le Directeur
sans fin pour le sirbat
bonjour madame la Présidente Monsieur le
vice-président monsieur le rapporteur ma
gamme et Messieurs les sénateur je vous
remercie déjà de pour cette invitation
pour participer à cette table ronde
autour de la question de la rénovation
énergétique
dans mes propos introductifs je pourrais
vous dire que la question la rénovation
énergétique je est on la traite nous
aussi abattre depuis bas sa naissance je
dirais depuis 2009 au même moment où la
réglementation effectivement est à Dom a
été publiée pour une mise en application
2010 puisque c'est cette année-là
correspond effectivement à la création
de notre pôle et notre première champ
d'intervention était effectivement comme
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure
madame la Présidente nous sommes un
service de la Chambre des Métiers donc
nous travaillons avant tout pour les
très petites entreprises et PME du
secteur du bâtiment et notre pôle est à
table nu effectivement en soutien en
appui technique à ces entreprises en
leur offrant effectivement baby en
développant de la formation autour la
question de cette réglementation donc au
départ et de et au fil des années
effectivement nous sommes structurés
pour développer pas mal de choses
notamment autour de tout ce qui est
matériaux les enjeux effectivement
au-delà du shabbat c'est aussi une
mobilisation des acteurs de la
construction à la Réunion que ce soit
les architectes les bureaux d'études les
assureurs nous sommes tous conscients
des enjeux qu'il faut mettre en avant
pour traiter cette question et améliorer
le la rénovation énergétique de de nos
bâtiments à la réunion nous nous avons
effectivement un foncé de plus en plus
réduit avec des demandes de logement de
plus en plus importantes
et il faut effectivement prendre
également en compte le vieillissement de
la population et également aussi une
certaine part de de la population qui
qui est dans la précarité et donc nous à
travers de notre activité de tous les
jours
nous essayons effectivement d'apporter
des solutions
sur cette problématique et et
accompagner au mieux les professionnels
vous aurez l'occasion je pense tout à
l'heure dans les questions qui me seront
posées j'aurai l'occasion de vous
présenter un certain nombre d'actions je
veux pas être davantage
dans mon introduction si ce n'est
peut-être juste pour rappeler sur la
question de la de la rénovation
énergétique j'avais vos claqué sur des
matériaux aujourd'hui le sirbag en
réponse également à aussi une
orientation stratégique de la région
travail à mettre en œuvre et des schémas
stratégiques des schémas régionaux dans
le cas de la srd2i également de la
stratégie de spécialisation intelligente
qui a mis un axe fort au développement
de nouveaux matériaux pour effectivement
prendre en compte cela était plus révélé
lors de la crise covid en 2019 de la
vulnérabilité de notre territoire à
effectivement par rapport à tout ce qui
est importation à essayer de développer
des nouveaux matériaux à la Réunion donc
c'est c'est sur ce genre de d'action de
deux projets que nous intervenons dans
ce cadre de rénovation énergétique voilà
merci
terminé ce premier tour de table par
Monsieur Lefebvre au niveau du conseil
régional de l'ordre d'architectes de la
Réunion Mayotte
oui bonjour à tous
encore une fois merci à la commission
d'enquête et au sénateur donc de nous
donner la parole sur les sujets de
rénovation énergétique alors sur la
question donc de des enjeux il faut
noter que la principale différence avec
la métropole résine en fait dans le fait
qu'une zone intertropicale les critères
qui influent le confort sont pas limités
à la seule température
l'amélioration du confort réside dans la
maîtrise de nombreux critères comme
l'hygrométrie la vitesse de l'air
l'activité l'habillement les vis-à-vis
la porosité des façades etc des fois
c'est parfois contradictoire
à noter que l'indépendance énergétique
des DOM est loin d'être acquise et
l'éloignement des circuits logistiques
d'approvisionnement crée une énergie
chère à produire et fortement carboné
même si des solutions sont en cours
d'élaboration comme le soleil
etc
la loi de transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte impose aux outre-mer
d'atteindre l'autonomie énergétique en
2030 on en est encore loin
l'ensemble des réglementations
thermiques et énergétique métropolitaine
est fondée sur l'amélioration de la
performance des systèmes actifs tels que
le chauffage et la clim car il est
présupposé au moins pour le chauffage
qu'une installation préexiste c'est pas
le cas dans les outre-mer alors
peut-être or Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
bien sûr
car contrairement aux États-Unis ou plus
de 95% des constructions sont équipées
de climatisation l'équipement des
habitations
avec de tels dispositifs et faibles à la
Réunion en tout cas
savoir que l'usage de la climatisation
peut représenter 50% de la consommation
électrique d'un foyer
donc les enjeux réside davantage à
orienter la politique publique vers une
conception bioclimatique des logements
visant prioritairement à réduire l'usage
de la climatisation plutôt que d'en
améliorer la performance
sur l'état des lieux des consommations
juste pour rappel la consommation des
ménages représente 45 % de la
consommation énergétique de l'île de la
Réunion une consommation moyenne
annuelle d'un foyer réunionnais c'est
3500 kWh par an soit 650 euros par an
contre 5000 kWh par an en France
métropolitaine soit 1000 euros environ
par an
faut savoir que la généralisation des
chauffeurs l'absence de chauffage dans
les foyers explique cette situation
comme l'ont appelé mes collègues la RTA
2 mise en place en 2010 à La Réunion à
modifier considérablement la
configuration des logements collectifs
la double orientation des façades pour
la ventilation la pose de brasseurs
d'air dans les chambres les protections
solaires etc mais il faut savoir quand
même que les maisons individuelles qui
représentent 60% des constructions ne
respectent pas en règle générale la
réglementation RTL donne qui est
pourtant obligatoire
et encore plus dans le secteur informel
notamment à Mayotte
donc l'enjeu réside donc dans l'habitat
individuel pour nous mais dans la
simplification des dispositifs d'aide et
d'accompagnement à la rénovation par la
mise en place d'un dossier administratif
unique pour toutes les aides à la
rénovation avec un seul service
instructeur pour la collecte des
financements
voilà donc le but étant d'encourager la
rénovation énergétique dans les
logements individuels et les architectes
et les bureaux d'études ont toutes leurs
places dans ces audits
on parle de password thermique dans la
loi énergie climat je pense que ce terme
n'est pas adapté pour les zones
intercropicales telles que la Réunion
voilà donc vous l'avez rappelé donc les
classements des PE ne sont pas
obligatoires dans les domaines
concernant les matériaux biosourcés
alors il existe différents matériaux
utilisables pour améliorer la
performance des bâtiments pas seulement
en isolation
citer la brique de terre comprimé les
parpaings de pouzzolane qui sont donc
plutôt des des matériaux géosourcés mais
par contre qui se heurte au système
normatif et assuranti avec classique
comme le marquage CE les normes de
construction donc là on a des blocages
d'autre part les matériaux pour
l'isolation sont sensibles aux insectes
xylophages très présents dans les
domaines tels que la paille de coco la
boîte de cellulose ou la bagasse
alors étant donné le caractère limitant
de la filière locale nous on pense qu'il
convient de poursuivre les négociations
avec la Commission européenne pour la
mise en place d'une procédure de
normalisation simplifiée pour
l'importation des produits des produits
en provenance d'État
sans système comparable à celui de
l'Union européenne en dérogation du
marquage CE on propose donc un marquage
rupture
ultra périphérique
voilà enfin s'approvisionner en
matériaux bio sur C dans l'environnement
régional
concernant donc la synergie entre
les cyclones et la rénovation
énergétique oui bien sûr il y a des
interférences par exemple un volet
anticyclonique qui est très étanche ne
répond pas à ce que demande la rtadom
qui demande plutôt quelque chose de très
poreux donc là il y a une interférence
qu'on viendrait de les faire converger
davantage en privilégions des
réglementations sur les objectifs plutôt
que sur des règles prescriptives
alors pour nous il n'y a pas vraiment de
synergie dans le sens où la mise en
conformité aux règles de résidence
résistance cyclonique d'un habitat
améliorerait l'efficacité énergétique
l'inverse pourrait être vrai dans le
sens où revoir l'isolation en toiture ou
en façade ajouter des protections
solaires seraient l'occasion d'améliorer
le comportement d'un bâtiment face à un
cyclone donc encore une fois la
résistance parasyclonique passe avant
tout par le savoir-faire des entreprises
et des maîtrises d'oeufs
voilà
merci déjà pour ces premières
interventions je vais essayer peut-être
la parole à Monsieur le rapporteur
il serait intéressant aussi que
peut-être que vous ne fassiez un point
sur la couverture de l'ensemble des
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
en termes de
voilà maison France rénove du service
France rénov ou pas parce que on a cru
comprendre que si dans la métropole le
territoire était couvert à quasi 98%,
c'est pas le cas ou en tout cas dans
l'ensemble de l'Outre-mer et des
territoires et départements d'outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente et merci à
chacune de vos interventions et pour
aller poursuivre ce que disait madame la
Présidente peut-être c'est vrai que sur
voir comment vous êtes associé justement
à tout ce qui peut être mis en place à
travers France rénov et avec les
particularités justement de l'outre-mer
et les particularités à l'intérieur
encore puisque c'est vrai que si on
parle de sa pierre et unique long pas la
même chose que si on parle de la Réunion
ou de la Martinique ou de la Guadeloupe
etc donc avec des justement des
particularités très fortes mais ça va du
coup comment vous êtes vous êtes associé
bon on a un petit peu parlé sur la sur
la question du DPE
ça c'était peut-être une première
question il y avait je voulais savoir
aussi si en fait vous il y avait déjà
des exemples alors peut-être sur le
logement logement social mais pas que de
rénovation en fait de travaux de
rénovation qui était fait vraiment sur
un axe justement de réflexion de
rénovation thermique et notamment pour
le la pour le coup plutôt vers
l'adaptation en termes de en termes en
termes climatique et où est-ce que c'est
à chaque fois qu'il y a des travaux de
rénovation globale que là on commence à
penser à qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
améliorer en termes de d'amélioration
thermique quoi enfin en tout cas est-ce
que parce que c'est vrai que peut-être
que on se pose plus cette question là
sur sur le continent de se dire que on
va agir directement sur la rénovation
thermique parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
un lien très fort tout de suite avec la
facture énergétique et du coup voilà
comment comment du coup peut-être la
prise de décision pour agir sur
l'amélioration thermique se fait en tout
cas dans les différents
exemples que vous pouvez avoir j'avais
pu faire un participer à un rapport sur
justement le logement avec la délégation
en outre-mer et j'avais plutôt la partie
sur tout ce qui était justement
matériaux et comment associer justement
des matériaux plus
locaux en tout cas et nécessitant moins
de transport et comment on pouvait
adapter justement ces matériaux aux
besoins et c'est vrai que sur la
question de la rénovation thermique ça
il y avait aussi du sens en tout cas
d'utiliser des matériaux beaucoup plus
locaux ça a été parlé de la terre mais
il y en a il y en a également d'autres
mais c'est vrai qui était ressorti très
fortement la question
la question de la des normes à la fois
des normes pour entre guillemets ces
nouveaux matériaux en tout cas c'est
c'est matériaux qui étaient peut-être
moins moins utilisés et donc à la fois
de pouvoir avoir des normes des invités
techniques des questions d'assurance
derrière et puis vous en avez parlé
aussi sur la question de comment
utiliser des matériaux qui sont parfois
proximité sur des pays voisins mais qui
n'ont pas la marque c'est eux
européenne et donc il pouvait poser des
problèmes je me rappelle notamment de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon du coup qui
pouvait pas prendre du bois juste à côté
du bois canadien parce qu'on n'avait pas
les mêmes les mêmes types de
réglementation
et donc c'est vrai qu'on avait vu que
c'était un frein important mais du coup
si vous pouviez aussi peut-être nous
nous préciser en tout cas les besoins
qui peut y avoir dans ce dans ce sens là
et puis notamment aussi pour pour
limiter les
limiter les déplacements
et puis peut-être mais c'est une
question très précise et j'ai pas
compris sur les chauffe-eau les
chauffe-eau thermique vous avez parlé
sur le sur l'eau chaude en disant que ça
avait un coup à la fin en fonctionnement
qui était plus élevé et du coup je voilà
j'ai pas tout à fait compris la raison
de ce couple plus élevé au final par
rapport à un chauffe-eau électrique
classique
notamment dans les dans les dans les
charges merci
alors
qui veut commencer à répondre madame
Mathieu c'est à VOUS allez-y madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur ben
écoutez pour les chauffe-eau parce que
c'est vrai que c'est très technique vous
avez de la tuyauterie qui s'oxyde très
rapidement on n'est pas dans les mêmes
contextes y compris d'ailleurs
et du coup le fait d'avoir toute la
tuyauterie qui vous descend le
l'ECS l'eau chaude sanitaire produite
par les panneaux non pas photovoltaïques
mais solaire chauffe toute une
tuyauterie et puis qui est ramené
jusqu'à l'usager d'accord et donc
l'entretien de cette tuyauterie coûte
effectivement plus cher au bailleur et
Tonton du que les charges dus à cette
partie là une belle part revient
au locataire ça c'est le décret qu'il
est qu'il arrête et donc c'est tout à
fait naturel que ce soit refacturé au
locataire par conséquent effectivement
ils se retrouvent avec une charge qu'il
n'avait pas avant il faut savoir que
avant la RTA d'homme le bailleur social
ne mettez pas de l'eau chaude dans le
dans le dans le logement en tout cas je
parle là bien sûr des pays des Antilles
de la Guyane
c'est peut-être un peu moins vrai pour
pour la Réunion même s'il y a quand même
une belle part qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas équipée donc ça c'est pour le côté
technique juste pour le les matériaux
dire qu'il y a quand même des
initiatives locales qui sont prises pour
aller faire un vrai travail d'études le
Croate en Guadeloupe a créé donc le
symptôme du Croate est un véritable
exemple donc ils ont d'ailleurs des
financements je crois d'Action Logement
et de l'État qui on est présent aux
copines et on essaye de trouver des
matériaux biosourcés mais aussi qui ont
le passif et sur lesquels on a un retour
d'expérience qui permettrait d'avoir un
de jeter un regard neuf sur ces
matériaux pour en avoir un usage à la
fois intelligent parce que c'est local
c'est développement durable c'est le
circuit court mais aussi parce que une
question de coûts
du produit en question quel qu'il soit
d'ailleurs mais également aux questions
assurantielles et là le travail est
effectivement lancé pour avoir des
équivalences
européenne je crains quand même que ce
soit en tout cas je me veux je me veux
lucide sur cette question ce sera
nécessairement lent parce que c'est une
question qui touchera l'Europe quoi donc
moi je suis voilà je suis prudente sur
sur cette partie là vous aviez parlé des
financements donc je reviens sur les
financements et sur la planification en
tout cas pour ce qui relève du parc
social la planification la programmation
des opérations il y a il y a une belle
expérience en tout cas nous on a un très
très beau retour d'expérience vous
vouliez un exemple concret c'est en
Guadeloupe lors du plan de relance on
avait 15 millions pour l'ensemble des
territoires insultés marins il fallait
avoir trois critères liés à
l'environnement pour bénéficier du plan
de relance les 5 millions de la
Guadeloupe catégoriquement absorbés en
très peu de temps parce que les
bailleurs de la Guadeloupe avaient saisi
cette occasion pour conduire des travaux
de réhabilitation mais qui touchait avec
les avec les trois éléments donc il faut
faire des poules pour
pour que ce soit pertinent il faut que
ça touche il faut que ce soit élargi aux
questions de réhabilitation qui sont
nécessaires notamment aux Antilles donc
en Guadeloupe et en Martinique
particulièrement parce que vous avez une
question liée au vieillissement la
nécessité de l'adaptation PMR la
nécessité de également de parce que
c'est un parc aussi vétuste par moment
et donc quand on arrive à lier
généralement les enjeux qui sont liés à
la demande les enjeux qui sont liés au
vieillissement du parc à la nécessité
donc de réhabilitation et que beaucoup
vous coupez ça avec des questions
énergétiques c'est vrai qu'on arrive à
avoir de jolis projets en tout cas des
choses qui font que l'action publique
prend une dimension extrêmement
efficiente voilà j'ai envie de dire donc
c'est vrai que ça c'est une c'est une
chose qui pourrait être reproduite alors
on a beaucoup on a beaucoup milité j'ai
envie de dire pour que le crédit d'impôt
justement soit parce que vous savez dans
les territoires de l'outre-mer vous avez
des ménages avec des plus bas et les
coûts des travaux sont plus chers voilà
donc vous avez ce qu'on appelle l'effet
ciseaux et donc pour atténuer dans une
certaine mesure cet effet ciseaux vous
êtes obligé d'avoir des subventions où
tout le moins une action publique plus
importante pour soutenir ces
investissements a mis âge quasiment à 19
ans d'âge en fait c'est à peu près 22
ans la moyenne normalement c'est à
partir de 20 ans que votre logement en
tout cas les bâtiments commencent à
avoir besoin de de réhabilitation et
donc à ce moment là si on arrive à lier
l'écologie donc la nécessité de de
remettre enorme mais tout en ayant
d'autres objectifs à atteindre et qu'on
déploie le crédit d'impôt là on pourrait
on pourrait être très efficace donc
l'écoute sans plus cher les ménages sont
plus nécessiteux sans cela il me semble
avec toute l'objectif nécessaire que
c'est compliqué de porter le
source
on vous entend très mal là on est désolé
on commence à vous entendre très mal
vous entend plus là ça va oui
mais peut-être que si vous coupez la
caméra parce qu'on a des propos très
très hachés
parce que je ne voulais pas le faire
elles sont surtout sur les outre-mer ce
que vous avez
deux choses qui sont pas qui sont pas
évidentes c'est que les interventions
dans les outre-mer vous avez la LBU
alors jusqu'en 2021 c'était uniquement
pour les vous m'entendez oui oui
donc vous aviez la lvu qui intervenait
alors notamment je parle du propriétaire
pour le coup privé sur les propriétaires
très modestes et donc ça c'était un vrai
sujet parce que dans l'Hexagone
les ménages modestes et très modeste
vous avez la fiscalité dans une certaine
mesure parce que vous savez quand on
construit un logement neuf comme on
avait la défiscalisation c'est des
éléments constitutifs de la construction
et donc ils étaient intégrés donc
quelque part on peut considérer que
c'était le public elle touche aussi la
partie énergétique enfin en tout cas
l'équipement écho de du bâtiment
on a effectivement le EDF qui qui
intervient mais pour EDF c'est plutôt
pour le c'était moi j'appelle ça une
politique d'équipement ou de gains de
confort plus qu'autre chose
sauf peut-être pour la partie isolation
ou là effectivement on est dans la
performance mais c'est vrai que c'était
un élément les aides d'EDF ça a vraiment
changé quelque part les façons de faire
en tout cas les usages des locataires
dans le parc national parce
qu'aujourd'hui et la mesure est
désormais faite et prise 20% de nos
locataires demandent un équipement c'est
à peu près 20% alors que il n'y a pas de
d'équipement de refroidissement en temps
normal on se contente de la de
l'application de la rtadom et donc pas
de clim à la maison après mettez à côté
quand même que pour certains ménages qui
veulent avoir un confort acoustique plus
important donc ils ferment et ils
isolent et puis après ils mettent la
clim donc voilà alors les certificats
d'économie d'énergie je trouve
effectivement qu'en gagnerait mais je
crois que le cadre de leur intervention
est plus limitée que celui de l'Hexagone
je laisse peut-être la parole à mes
collègues
merci qui c'est qui
monsieur chanfain
merci le président monsieur le
rapporteur si vous me perds me permettez
je voulais revenir sur
les
propos de Monsieur le rapporteur qui qui
évoquait la question des matériaux
locaux l'utilisation des matériaux
locaux et à ce titre j'aimerais
peut-être rappeler un petit peu un petit
historique des de cette de cette
question pour la Réunion puisque les
travaux étaient engagés je dirais à
partir de 2017 au travers d'une étude
qu'on avait lancé à cette époque
s'intitulait isobiodome alors l'étude a
été rendue en 2019 et a pu mettre en
évidence effectivement sur la base d'un
certain
sur la base de ressources locales que
nous avons prélevé donc il s'agissait du
crypto-meria du vétiver du bois de
goyavier et de la bagasse cette étude
effectivement avait démontré
effectivement des des caractéristiques
très intéressantes au niveau des
performances thermiques de ces matériaux
de ces matériaux et
cette étude a été le point de départ je
dirais pour lancer une dynamique autour
de cette question des matériaux
bio-social à la Réunion puisque elle a
été prise par et intéresser un certain
nombre d'entreprises et globalement ça
permet aussi de comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure dans en introduction d'orienter
aussi des de la stratégie de
développement autour de cette question
des matériaux à la Réunion à travers de
la S5
et cette étude également mis en avant un
certain nombre de difficultés que nous
avons rencontré lors de cette étude il
s'agissait d'une étude qui avait
bénéficié du du programme d'amélioration
la construction transition énergétique
le programme pack et avait mobilisé
l'intervention du CSTB du FCBA
et
suite à cette étude si vous voulez on
appuie effectivement on est en train de
travailler en ce moment à structurer
davantage la filiale des matériaux
biosourcés puisque on a pu mettre en
effectivement en évidence des points
positif mais également des points
négatifs notamment sur la question la
durabilité des matériaux
vis-à-vis d'un insecte long nous nous
retrouvons en climat tropical qui qui
sont les termites et également à la
Réunion encore plus à la réunion nous
avons un peu particulier effectivement
en présence ensoleillée sur le littoral
et des commente un altitude nous
souffrons effectivement
d'une augmentation d'unité d'humidité
des risques de condensation du
développement des moisissures et
lorsqu'on parle de matériaux bio soit
effectivement ils sont
ils sont
comment j'ai ça ils sont affectés par
ces
[Musique]
c'est ces contraintes là les les
insectes et l'humidité et au-delà de ça
on a pu également mettre bien en
évidence que localement il y avait une
nécessité de d'avoir davantage de
davantage la recherche notamment en
termes de moyens d'essai puisque nous
sommes très loin de la métropole lorsque
l'on réalise ce type d'études et ce type
de recherche il faut mobiliser un
certain nombre de matières grises et
d'équipements scientifiques et toute la
l'idée aujourd'hui dans cet
accompagnement que l'on souhaite offrir
à des entreprises locales s'inscrire
dans le développement des matériaux bio
sensés c'est d'avoir un accompagnement
au plus juste pour répondre au mieux à
leurs besoins donc aujourd'hui il y a
des partenariats qui sont notamment
développés à la biodiversité de la
Réunion pour effectivement avoir et
acquérir des équipements pour pouvoir
développer des prototypes
se pose après ce posera la question
effectivement la question de la
normalisation comment faire reconnaître
ces nouveaux matériaux localement
notamment s'il souhaite si on le
souhaite les inscrire dans des
programmes de rénovation ou peut-être
même de construction neuve je pense à
des nouveaux isolants par exemple va se
poser la question de comment les faire
reconnaître la question de la
certification des talons pour au niveau
surtout des assurés apporter toute la
confiance dans ces nouveaux matériaux et
là je tiens également à rappeler un
des actions et un projet qui qui est
mené porté par la Fédération des
Entreprises d'outre-mer la FEDOM qui
travaille effectivement à la mise en
place nos cellules locales de validation
de la conformité donc tout l'objectif
sera effectivement sur la base des
travaux qui sont réalisés par
suite à la recherche d'avoir une
certaine porosité entre le monde de la
recherche et le monde de l'économie
donc là c'est voilà je voulais rappeler
ça pour vous montrer effectivement qu'il
y avait des choses qui sont qui sont
engagées qui sont en train d'être menées
sur cette question des matériaux
biosourcés avec un certain nombre de
partenaires et Monsieur le rapporter
avait également évoqué tout à l'heure la
question comment nous déployons nous
mettons en œuvre la question de la
France rénov la prime rénove en tout cas
non en tant que chambre de métier il y a
des conventions de partenariat notamment
qui sont menées avec EDF nous déployons
au travers de nos centres de formation
des formations autour de tout ce qui est
RTA d'hommes et également
l'accompagnement des entreprises à
obtenir la mention RGE et
systématiquement dans le cadre de ces
formations à destination de nos
entreprises des intervenants d'EDF
peuvent intervenir effectivement vous
présenter les aides dans le cas la
compensation territoire dans le cadre
des territoriales de compensation pardon
et également
d'exposer et de présenter tous les
dispositifs d'aide associé à ma prime
rénov
voilà et enfin il y a un dernier point
que j'aimerais là vous vous soumettre
qui qui met également apporté à la fois
en écoutant certaines entreprises mais
également d'autres partenaires tels que
SPL horizon qui
œuvrent également à déployer ces
dispositifs sur le territoire qui
concernent effectivement une très grande
complexité dans l'instruction des
dossiers de ma prime rénov
et il y avait également autre chose
il s'agissait également de mettre en
également en évidence une certaine
inadéquation en des bouquets de travaux
présents dans ma prime rénove et des
spécificités que nous retrouvons
notamment à la Réunion certains bouquets
de travaux ne sont pas forcément
en réponse directe à des besoins local
voilà
est-ce que vous êtes également
confrontés à des problématiques de
fraude
ou de malfaçon et donc voilà est-ce que
est-ce que vous avez des
exemples est-ce que c'est souvent des
choses qui vous remontent ou tentent du
côté
des entreprises que des particuliers
alors moi mon niveau je n'ai pas ce
retour d'information
mais je pourrais éventuellement prendre
note et questionner partenaires autour
de moi et vous apporter une réponse
prochaine
ok on va peut-être passer à Monsieur
Lefebvre et puis on reviendra ici dans
la salle en présentiel
juste pour compléter donc les propos
sur le choix de solaire en tant que
architecte effectivement et je peux
comprendre que le coup soit plus élevé
qu'un chauffe-eau électrique puisque en
fait la technologie mise en place
nécessite quand même beaucoup plus de
d'efforts de plomberie et génère plus de
sinistre donc qui définissent dit
intervention du bailleur pour réparer la
panne ou le dégât donc je crois qu'il se
développe également en ce moment une
alternative donc de chauffe-eau alimenté
par les panneaux solaires
je pense qu'effectivement ça ça améliore
en tout cas ça réduit il me semble le
nombre de sinistres du fait de l'absence
de plomberie en tout cas limité dans le
logement
concernant la rénovation des logements
collectifs sociaux moi ce que je
constate dans les appels d'offres de des
bailleurs locaux c'est que on a des
degrés donc de rénovation qui sont sur
trois stades on va dire on a le stade 1
qui concerne les équipements intérieurs
donc on va dire plutôt de l'équipement
intérieur de la mise en accessibilité
PMR des salles de bain etc donc qui est
fait
100% des cas deuxième stage de la
rénovation énergétique donc la pose
souvent de voler
l'installation de CS la pose de bardage
et le stage 3 c'est la création de
surface donc ça c'est assez rare mais
dans ce que je constate le stage 1 et 2
sont souvent réunis pour créer donc un
marché plus conséquent qui intéresse
davantage les entreprises et les
architectes
concernant
la formation en tout cas la capacité des
architectes à répondre à Franz runov un
sujet j'ai regardé donc les statistiques
sur 5400 architectes
référencés dans la rubrique architecte
du site France rénov il y en a 45 dans
les autres-mères donc effectivement
c'est peu il y a lors des architectes et
force de proposition en tout cas
communique sur le sujet de plus en plus
pour
solliciter les architectes et les faire
rentrer dans ce dans ce marché mais la
question c'est aussi la formation et
je sais que l'école d'architecture
propose donc depuis peu une forme dans
sa formation initiale du cycle Master un
enseignement sur le déjà là et qui va
s'étoffer à la rentrée il aborde aussi
la aussi bien la réhabilitation que la
rénovation la mutabilité la
réversibilité
l'adapter l'adaptabilité ou le réemploi
la décarbonation
donc ça va plutôt dans le bon sens mais
pour l'instant effectivement la
situation peut être améliorée
alors messieurs qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire en complément et au
regard des questions posées par le
rapporteur s'il vous plaît merci
oui donc je vais apporter un complément
très bref et rapide sur le sujet de
l'eau chaude sanitaire qui était aussi
un sujet dans l'Hexagone avec la RT 2012
et le développement massif de cette
solution qui a amené à des fois des
mauvaises prescriptions et donc des
déboires en termes d'entretien donc il y
a assez un sujet déjà de fond présent un
peu partout
donc là on était sur l'obligation
effectivement de ce 50% de solaire
thermique pour répondre au sujet de
l'eau chaude sanitaire un des projets
d'évolution de la rt2a d'hommes dans sa
nouvelle version c'est d'ouvrir au moins
à 50% de chaleur renouvelable dans le
sens où ouvrir un peu peut-être le champ
des possibles techniquesment
à la nuance près que à date les pompes à
chaleur semblerait déjà exclues du sujet
et j'avais un doute sur les panneaux
photovoltaïques notamment qui étaient
avancés je sais plus ce qui avait dit la
DHP sur le thème donc bon on ouvre le
champ des possibles mais peut-être pas
tant que ça
concernant les matériaux la question
porte de manière entre guillemets
textuelle sur les biosourcés ça déjà été
évoqué avant on peut l'ouvrir tout de
suite au géo-sourcés j'ai même envie de
l'ouvrir ou réemploi parce que
globalement l'ensemble des matériaux
qu'on aura à la fois entre guillemets
sous le coude qui permet de répondre aux
besoins d'approvisionnement peut-être en
coups et aussi surtout en décarbonation
toujours dans l'idée de faire venir de
manière très coûteuse en carbone et en
capitaux de la ressource extérieure à
ces domaines donc là pour le coup le
logement social dans son sens très large
c'est un berceau d'innovation assez
fertile les bailleurs sont très friands
d'innovation échangent beaucoup entre
eux sur ces thématiques s'associe à des
dispositifs expérimentaux à des
industriels qui veulent tenter d'innover
entrer dans ces cycles d'innovation donc
là il y a plusieurs solutions qui ont
été qui ont déjà été évoqués comme
comme la brille comme le j'ai perdu le
terme isodone de ISO Biodôme Biodôme de
la Réunion on pourra ajouter aussi
d'autres recherches en ce moment dans
les Antilles autour des algues Sargasses
ou on a encore l'état de
d'expérimentation mais peut-être de
trouver un petit peu de guillemets une
solution qui permet à la fois de jurer
une de gérer le sujet de prolifération
des algues et trouver des ressources
supplémentaires en matériaux trouver un
débouché finalement peut-être à la fois
trouver une réponse pertinente aux deux
thématiques
donc pour tout ça on va retrouver tous
les problèmes qu'on a globalement dès
qu'on envisage le matériau innovation
c'est-à-dire qu'il va falloir quelqu'un
pour vous produire la matière en amont
quelqu'un pour la transformer souvent
derrière éventuellement la qualifier
quelqu'un pour la prescrire efficacement
parce que c'est pas parce que la matière
la matière est disponible qu'elle va
être prescrite soit par mes
connaissances soit par prudence après il
faut qu'elle soit effectivement
correctement mise en oeuvre sur chantier
et enfin seulement après elle est
réceptionnée éventuellement entretenu et
voir à la fin peut-être déposer
revaloriser donc tout ça c'est un cycle
avec entre guillemets beaucoup de ici
dans la boucle à faire tomber
sachant que entre guillemets tant qu'on
n'a pas réussi à boucler cette boucle on
va être dans une dans une espèce de
hold-up à la mexicaine comme on pourrait
dire entre d'un côté les clients qui
attendent que l'offre existe et dans
notre côté les industriels qui attendent
que la demande existe pour construire
l'offre donc comment on va réussir à
amorcer la machine l'avantage c'est que
comme on l'a dit le logement social peut
être un bon allié justement pour lancer
ces mécaniques et ses filières
des initiatives existent déjà dans
l'Hexagone d'autres très probablement
aussi dans les territoires dont j'ai pas
encore entendu parler c'est quelque
chose d'assez courant ces notions de
partenariat de voire même des fois
monter une filière Haddock pour répondre
à un besoin spécifique
donc dans les limites aussi qu'on a
évoqué et peut-être qu'on a pas assez
vite c'est les notions de coûts et
surtout parce que à l'arrivée on veut
non seulement produire local bas carbone
mais aussi social donc toujours la
notion de réussir à maîtriser les coûts
de production pour les bailleurs sociaux
sachant qu'on l'a rappelé Canada encore
supérieur sur ces territoires sur
l'hexagone dans des territoires où les
bailleurs sont plus récents encore plus
endettés parce que encore en trait de
constituer le parc entre guillemets zéro
donc on se retrouve avant la
superposition de ces problématiques on
l'a beaucoup évoqué aussi le sujet
d'assurance et comme avant j'ai envie de
rappeler le sujet d'être capable de le
prescrire c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'il
y ait des architectes des maîtres
d'oeuvre des bureaux qui les connaissent
qui sachent les mettre en oeuvre des
contrôleur techniques qui les accepte la
capacité aussi à produire des
dérogations en technique les ATEX en
temps et en heure sur ces matériaux
puisque la plupart sont justement pas
encore en technique courantes donc il va
falloir les faire rentrer dans ces
mécaniques la notion de de marquage de
peut-être
veut dire que le marquage chez eux c'est
le bon niveau ou pas ce qui a pas un
autre type de marquage à envisager
aussi je n'ai pas dit mais une fois
qu'on va produire localement la matière
ça va te dire aussi effectivement
comment la qualifie comme j'ai dit
discrètement donc on n'a pas forcément
accès à tout l'arbre de compétences et
techniques de demande de mesure sur tous
les territoires qu'on pourrait avoir
dans l'Hexagone donc comment qualifier
rapidement ces matériaux être sûr de
leur réplicabilité en termes de qualité
on va dire de intrinsèque sur ces
matériaux qu'on va mettre en place
je pense avoir été un peu près complet
là dessus
autre chose également que je vais
ajouter sur le cas du logement social on
est dans une logique généralement donc
de parc vous êtes dans un réseau donc
des acteurs qui dialogue entre eux qui
sont des acteurs du temps long donc ils
ont souvent une logique d'échelle de
planification à distance avec le fait
d'être capable d'embarquer plusieurs
sujets en un la réhabilitation
généralement s'arrête pas au sujet de la
thermique on embarque aussi
l'accessibilité le vieillissement la
biodiversité
donc c'est souvent des enjeux qui sont
déjà naturellement inscrits dans ces
cycles qui va falloir continuer à
soutenir pour éviter d'avoir de
resserrer justement le SCOP peut-être en
face à l'urgence et malheureusement
oublier d'autres sujets qui vont être
capitaux au cycle au cycle suivant comme
l'économie circulaire oui que j'ai
évoqué plus tôt si on s'embarque juste
bio et j'ai ressourcé c'est dommage de
pas embarquer aussi la revalorisation de
ces matières avec déjà beaucoup d'enjeux
sur l'hexagone là dessus mais encore
plus dans le sens où si on veut être
capable de remplir les matières
potentiellement va falloir la stocker
qui dit stockage des surfaces foncières
disponibles on en a déjà peu disponible
pour faire ce qu'on veut faire à date la
sécuriser la requalifier être capable de
la réassurer la remettre en oeuvre et
donc pour ça aussi l'avantage ces
réseaux ça s'observe déjà dans
l'Hexagone des bailleurs monte leur
propre plateforme de réemploi pour
faciliter le sujet en étant eux-mêmes
producteurs et reconsommateur
de matière ça permet d'éviter des
notions des fois d'intermédiaires et
d'avoir une meilleure vision sur la
temporalité des différents projets voir
d'être capable de mieux anticiper des
phénomènes de glissement ou d'attente
d'un projet à un autre ou d'un bailleur
d'enregistrement en intervalier
tout ça je l'ai dit oui bon la notion
aussi d'être associée donc j'ai pas moi
les chiffres de mon côté je les connais
pas je sais pas si mon collègue pour en
donner plus sur les sujets de France
rénov et des aides et des dispositifs
qui existent là par exemple
sur les territoires peut-être la notion
de d'antenne locale que je n'ai pas du
tout la vision mais de manière plus
Macron on sait que le logement social à
l'avantage d'être comme très souvent
associé à tout ce qui est création et
mise à jour des dispositifs de
financement tout ce qui va être
évolution de l'appareil législatif et
réglementaire là on l'a vu autour de
l'évolution de la rt2a d'homme le
logement social et associé pour
l'évolution qui va principalement
toucher le neuf pour tout ce qui va être
des PE les bailleurs sociaux sont
également embarqués pour être sûr
d'obtenir un outil qui va être pertinent
mais entre guillemets au pluriel sur
l'ensemble des territoires ça c'était
assez
souligné et également sur les mises à
jour des outils et les leviers de
financement qui lui sont propres autour
des échos prêts et des choses comme ça
associé à des contreparties de
performance qui embarquent justement
beaucoup de sujets autres que purement
la vision entre guillemets hexagonale de
qu'est-ce que la performance énergétique
dans un bâtiment
ça tout pour moi dans l'immédiat je
pense
non effectivement ce que des messieurs
Lefebvre aujourd'hui on a quelque chose
d'assez parce que je vous propose c'est
vous remettre les éléments dans la note
ce sera plus complet avec une meilleure
cartographie une meilleure couverture
que sinon on va aller sur tous les
territoires et je pense que au moment de
donner une fois un peu plus de temps
pour pouvoir les débloquer si vous
permettez est-ce que l'une ou l'un
d'entre vous aurait quelque chose à
rajouter
le rapporteur
je sais pas si vous souhaitez rajouter
quelque chose au-delà des éléments que
vous pourrez nous faire parvenir dans
les meilleurs délais néanmoins
non
oui monsieur Lefebvre oui juste vous
informer que à la Réunion donc il y a un
logiciel qui est en cours de
constitution qui s'appelle armure art
plus loin n u R e donc qui est porté par
l'ASP et l'horizon imagine EDF et qui va
donc aider à créer une modélisation
thermique de l'existant pour appliquer
les améliorations énergétiques et
permettre une classification des PE
également un projet qui est porté en
partie par le Conseil de l'Ordre des
architectes camions Mayotte qui est
culture et climat qui propose un outil
d'aide au concepteur sous format BIM qui
vérifie donc les projets au stade de la
conception sur le confort thermique
voilà des choses sur lesquelles je
pensais c'est important de vous signaler
merci beaucoup monsieur Vasseur vous
vouliez rajouter quelque chose oui je
voulais rajouter quelque chose mais je
vais en profiter pour rebondir également
sur les propos monsieur l'architecte à
distance c'était autour du effectivement
le niveau dispositif de de DPE et de DPA
rt2a d'homme se veut unifier dans le
sens où le but c'est d'obtenir une
espèce de vision un peu unique à la fois
sur le neuf et l'existant qui pour le
coup pourrait potentiellement avoir
quasiment 10 ans d'avance sur ce qu'on a
prévu de faire l'Hexagone parce que
l'exercice est privé aussi mais à terme
donc effectivement cet outil
réunion il fait partie des outils qui
vont être étudiés par la DHP dans cet
exercice d'unification
des modèles et des dispositifs sachant
que forcément il faut que ça s'adapte
encore une fois à l'ensemble de ces
territoires donc modulo potentiellement
des ajustements sur les moteurs
dernier point que j'avais en tête
ah oui je voulais revenir vite fait sur
Saint-Pierre et Miquelon dont on a que
esquissé donc nous on avait commencé à
rentrer en contact avec le Point Info
Énergie chez eux qui voulaient échanger
sur le sujet donc là malheureusement ça
peut plus faire attendre mais on bien
sûr on abondera avec les éléments qu'on
pourra récupérer auprès d'eux sur le
sujet la seule chose qu'on sait à date
sans connaître à la fois la portée et
l'efficacité des aides sur l'isolation
existent sur ce territoire porter déjà
depuis de nombreuses années donc je
pense qu'il doit avoir commencé à avoir
des retours chiffrés peut-être sur
l'efficacité de leur de leurs mesures et
également qui était de ça aussi il y a
beaucoup d'efforts qui sont portés sur
même si l'énergie encore massivement
fossiles de passer par des réseaux
collectifs urbains pour pouvoir gagner
des notions de rendement avec de la
cogénération sur ces territoires donc il
y a des il y a des briques qui sont
avancés effectivement ça progresse sur
le sujet mais on n'a pas les chiffres et
les états fin à date et on espère avoir
un petit peu plus d'éléments d'ici là on
voit au final du document qu'on fera
parvenir très bien merci beaucoup plus
personne n'a quelque chose à rajouter
non et bien en tout cas on vous remercie
très sincèrement d'avoir participé à
cette table ronde à la fois en visio et
en présentiel alors je sais pas quelle
heure il est chez vous si on vous
souhaite bon après-midi
bon déjeuner je sais plus là
bonne nuit pour moi
en tout cas
merci beaucoup merci à vous et n'hésitez
pas à nous faire remonter tous types
d'informations qui nous sera encore
nécessaire
au revoir